Want to know what's heating up in
theaters this weekend?
- This ancient power has returned, the ultimate evil.
Adventure and an ancient horror combined in The Mummy, starring Tom Cruise and Russell Crowe.
- You saw that, right?
- We never go out at night.
- I think they're sick.
A man will do anything to protect his family deep in the woods in "It Comes At Night".
- Can't trust anyone but family.
- What are you going to do with her?
- Confront her.
- Come in.
"My Cousin Rachel" is a period piece mystery about a man trying to uncover the truth behind a recent death.
- You're delusional. [screaming]
- No, wait!
See what's hot in theaters with this week's fanticipation.
So, what's your weekend ticket going to be?
Let us know by commenting.
See you next time on weekend ticket.